Madhumitha Janagaraja
First it was just unhealthy, and I remember when the air was 162 on the [Air Quality Index],
I was like, Oh god, I can't breathe in this.
And then it got to 245. That was the first day that was “hazardous”.
And it was really bad, like that
was when the smoke alarms were going off.
But come January, we reached eight times hazardous levels.
People said it reached 15 [times].
And when it got to that point, it seemed neverending.
I think that's when we realised: this is a crisis,
this isn't going anywhere.
And the sense of desolation
that was there was profound, because I think we couldn’t see an end in sight,
we couldn’t see a way out.
And the worst thing about any emergency or any bad situation I think is when you
don't see a way forward.
There was nothing that people could do except hide away from the smoke, and there
were very, very few places to actually hide. Staying indoors –
smoke was still getting in through the buildings.
Air purifiers, not strong enough.
Everything was sold out.
I think
there was a lot of hopelessness, a lot of panic in the people that I saw,
and it was quite a struggle to not feel helpless in the situation.